i got i got my [ __ ] purple horror wig
on want a date
it did on a date
nice need some coffee got any money got
any money
yeah name of the movie is called
frankenhooker yeah [ __ ] yeah we're
talking about frankenhooker yeah this is
this movie is a [ __ ] masterpiece how
can you not love frank and i had never
seen it you had never seen it before oh
my god
this is a great [ __ ] movie no this is
up there with the velocipaster
velocipaster was another [ __ ] great
movie a masterpiece of
of this kind of this kind of movie where
of like trash
trashy as [ __ ] it's a it's a cheap ass
[ __ ] movie it knows it's a cheap ass
movie you know that it knows that you
know it's
cheap they're gonna [ __ ] lean into
the [ __ ] they're just gonna entertain
the [ __ ]
out of you this thing was was this movie
was made by troma
which is i've never seen it it was put
out by a trauma yeah
put out by trump i've never seen a
trauma movie i just heard about them you
never saw toxic adventure no
that's probably their best known one
never saw it i have to see them all now
yeah you probably have a lot of they all
have different directors that's kind of
like a production company
but uh the director of this one is frank
hennenlotter he was the same guy that
did
basket case that was good one and two
yeah and also did a
great trauma movie uh no i don't i don't
well did trauma put that one out i don't
think so
uh the movie he also did uh brain damage
the one about the guy with the thing
that grows out of a
yeah ailment that grows out of his
that's also a great movie but i think
that frankenhooker might be my favorite
one of his
i think that brain damage and
frankenhooker were filmed around the
same time like 1988
but this one didn't come out until 1990.
yeah you know what i'm saying so yeah so
um
this was shot uh in new york as many of
his movies are because i
his movies always have that kind of like
really grimy
new york city kind of energy which i
always really liked like everything's
like really
[ __ ] filthy and yeah a lot of it
looks sleazy and
a lot of it looked like it was shot in
new york that one club
it was yeah it was trashy looking nasty
old school new york yeah yeah when it
was like when it was almost like detroit
yeah when it was just like this scuzzy
[ __ ] but yeah but it's like this
movie is like sleazy but like in a
really really fun
entertaining way yeah i looked up that
club that's in there
that was called what was it called uh
huevos grande
yeah big balls yeah um
that actually i think they actually did
build that um as a set but it was based
on a real nightclub that they were going
to use but then it had closed
all right you know what i mean so i
guess they kind of like used a club that
it closed this is this movie's kind of
like
in some ways like it's like frankenstein
it's almost kind of like reanimator in a
certain way too
um it's it's a good story
very straightforward real understandable
it's not something that you have to
[ __ ] really think about you just
watch it
and it's about this dude living out in
[ __ ] was it queens
no he's in new jersey okay just over the
bridge he's in new jersey
and his girlfriend dies and but he has
this
technology based on estrogen all right
where he can preserve
female body parts and keep him alive and
put them back together and then shock
him and make a
like a frankenstein and he's trying to
bring his girlfriend back to life and
he's [ __ ] crazy too
all right he's he's nuts he kind of
reminds me of my friend a little swole
from new york and he's a lot like little
swallow
he does actually he looks a little bit
like absolutely
it's the kind of [ __ ] little swole would
try to do or think about talking
same kind of personality you know yeah
like you know i think we could sew this
woman together and and we'd probably
give her back to life man
he's kind of so kind of like it's kind
of some of the [ __ ] he was doing oh i'm
sorry you know
it's kind of the [ __ ] the [ __ ] little
swell would do but uh and he's not swole
he used to kind of be swollen but he's
not he's
i gotta [ __ ] with him anyway
so the dude uh his girlfriend dies and
he's keeping the brain alive
and uh he's trying to figure out ways to
get bodies
and female bodies and make a
frankenstein and put her brain back in
and bring her back alive i mean it's the
oldest thing ever but it's
not so [ __ ] simple okay nothing comes
up
he he's addicted to drilling holes in
his head yeah there's
that because he went to he went to a
medical school so he knows where to
drill
and he enjoys it and he gets his [ __ ]
uh ideas
yeah on how to solve problems by
drilling a hole in his head
crazy [ __ ] don't try this at home
he uh goes down and tries to um
make friends with these hookers and
[ __ ] he makes a deal with the with
the pimp his name is zoro wouldn't it
yeah
zorro yeah zorro is a big [ __ ] roided
out kind of mexican dude
i think that dude was i think that dude
was in brain damage as well i think a
lot of these actors were also in brain
damage because i think like i said they
shot him around the scene
he tries to hire all these girls to come
to this private party
where he's gonna figure out which one he
wants i guess and
uh
this is like he's gonna ply him with
crack but he's gonna prime with this he
makes this super crack
and hookers cannot resist crack all
right
yeah which everyone knows everybody
knows that
this crack man i don't know if i don't
know if i want to spoil this movie
everybody's saying come on everybody's
saying frank can hook up this crack he
tries it out on a rabbit first wanted a
rabbit or
no it was it was a uh it was a no it was
uh is it a dog
no it wasn't no was it it was a it was a
only a couple days not a gerbil what's
that other thing called hamster no
was it's bigger than hamster guinea pig
guinea pig there you go
why can't i think of that i don't know
i'm stupid
and uh he makes the guinea pig smoke
crack and it blows up
yeah well all the hookers come to his
[ __ ] party
and he's having like a hooker beauty
contest he's putting check marks on them
measuring all their stuff and they see
the crack
and they can't resist it so they jump
jump on him like in this big orgy thing
he's like no don't smoke the crack don't
smell the crack
they start smoking the crack there's
huge rocks up he
he had like a one gallon ziplock bag a
[ __ ] crap
super crap yeah and the crack the rock
was like
it was like sugar cane in that rock
candy
that's what it was
and the hookers are just freaking out
wow and they're smoking it
look at all this crack yeah and they
start blowing up
so yeah zoro shows up wants to know how
one of his hookers and [ __ ] he gets
hit with a head
you're an explosion that knocks his ass
i love it again just thinking about it
yeah
so he wakes up he's got all these body
parts don't worry ladies this is all by
accident i'm gonna put you all back
together and he's
he's taking bags a ziploc bag big big
trash bags full of hooker parts he takes
them out puts them in his trunk
and he puts him in his solution and they
all [ __ ] are in there kind of
pieces moving so he starts thinking he
starts building like the ultimate body
for his girlfriend out of these hooker
fragments
and hooker fragments yeah yeah well they
did they they fragged out when they blew
up
and they fracked out so what we call the
military hook-up
yeah man and so he does build a badass
woman out of these pieces and puts the
brain in it and it comes up that's just
[ __ ] hilarious because
it's a couple different races of girls
that he [ __ ] sewed together so
some parts are white some parts are kind
of tan and you know
some were asian parts and black parts
[Laughter]
man like variety you know
[Laughter]
she comes out and when she appears once
she comes a lot he brings it to life and
when it comes to life it's already got a
person everything
and starts walking down the [ __ ]
street it escapes
it's sucking men [ __ ] sucking their
souls out it's electric power
somehow it doesn't explain well she's
like electrocute pretty much
and it's this somehow rejuvenates her
too she can grab a minute remember that
it was it would kill him
yeah and i thought it was was it taking
energy from him
i'm not really sure i don't think they
thought about it all that much but she
had blue hair too didn't she
yeah well that's why i told you to wear
that she had blue hair and blue nipples
well they were purple purple yeah
apparently there was another scene in
there that they took out
that she also had purple pubic hair okay
yeah but i guess they did they took that
scene out she started
frank and hooker on her way down and she
instantly starts turning tricks got any
money
you know nina company and she's just
like a robot
going down she's like walking all
awkward and stuff i love the way she
walked in this it like cracked yeah she
had the big platforms and everything and
first one of the first dudes she runs
across on the street his old
fat little simp middle-aged simp and
he's just that
was the dude from like the miracle whip
commercial back in the 80s do you
remember that
blown yeah
there's always one yeah she takes him up
to a [ __ ]
cheap hotel he just runs right in and
she's doing monster [ __ ] he's loving it
it's [ __ ] funny monster [ __ ] yeah
he was in on it he's like oh okay yeah
yeah [ __ ] with the purple nipples and
everything's like whoa
he was a sip you know [ __ ] he looked
like a little danny devito type dude you
know he was just happy to get some
action
and uh he was impressed she blew his ass
up and the head goes that was great
it was [ __ ] great did he say that was
great or you're the best or something
something like that
yeah that's [ __ ] funny so she goes
and it's just
it's fun well over time she kind of
remembers who she is and she does kind
of become his girlfriend
but for a while she's like all five
hookers at once
saying different things yeah and her old
pip wants her back he thinks he he
thinks
that that all belongs to him yeah and uh
it's just
it's it's the only part that's elizabeth
elizabeth is the name
of um the brain well it's the head it's
the whole head
it was the whole head wasn't it yeah
yeah yeah well because what happened
was at the very beginning like our main
character's name is jeffrey franken
yeah um and he uh is marrying
elizabeth and they're having a birthday
party and jeffrey
who has gone to medical school they say
he got thrown out of three medical
schools right but he's also he's like an
electrical engineer
yeah so what do they call he's a
bioelectrical scientist he said right
so he has like a brain in his
uh in a tank in his room with a big
eyeball on it that he's trying to like
reanimate
which actually fun fact that prop
they made that because it was drawn on
the poster
of the old movie from the 50s the brain
that wouldn't die
and but it wasn't actually in the movie
so uh
frank henningwater was like well i'm
going to put that actually in the movie
because i was like bummed out that they
didn't put it in brandon
because it was so cool looking so he put
that in there so
uh so he has made for uh elizabeth's
dad's birthday
has made a remote control lawn mower
and elizabeth is trying to demonstrate
it and
the lawnmower runs her over and her
pieces go flying
everywhere and the reason that jeffrey
only has the head and
a foot and a hand right it's just like
she
he's only in like a thumb or something
those were the only pieces that he could
recover from the accident
like before everybody one of the
funniest things in this
is the news uh the news segment that
he's watching he's
videotaped it and he keeps watching it
over and over the news segment about the
accident
is just [ __ ] so [ __ ] funny today
the movie's got a really good ending i
don't think i'm not gonna spoil it just
in case you guys are new to it it's got
a fantastic ending
um it's a good story it's
basically kind of like reanimator um
except sleazier
sleazier and dirtier it's got lots of
nudity
um and naked [ __ ] blowing up
and it's just [ __ ] hilarious
it's it's got practical effects it's got
a good score
it's shot real well for what it is it's
a cheap movie that looks great
you're you're supposed to just watch it
and enjoy and marvel
it came out in 1990 so i was in the army
during that time yeah
had i known about it or had it come out
two years before and saw you know a year
before and i'd seen it we would have
loved it
we would have loved it but the thing is
i don't think blockbuster had this
they probably wouldn't rent this i don't
imagine it would be
something i think i rented it from like
i said i used to go to like kind of a
mom and pop
yeah that's a place where you have to so
that's where you more have to get it i
don't think blockbuster would carry
something like this
the ironic thing about this was that
frankenhooker
was um i guess when frank hennenlotter
was pitching
a movie he had a script written for it i
think it was called insect city
and he was pitching that and the
production company was like well you
know we don't want that
uh you got anything else it was just
kind of like that ed wood thing yeah and
he
thought of the concept of frankenhooker
just like on the fly yeah frankenhook
he's just like somebody with a bunch of
hooker body parts and they're like now
that we want to see yeah yeah
so he just like came up with it like off
the top of his head
i put it up there i think it's a
masterpiece man i loved it i really
enjoyed it
i'd see it again it was up there with um
reanimator it's up there with uh
basket case it's up there with i think
it's better than basket case
i think it is too i like basket case as
well but i think i like animator yeah
um i just liked it there there's
it's it oh it's up there it's definitely
up there with uh
a velocipaster yeah definitely if you
like velocipaster which is another
masterpiece
like a masterpiece of [ __ ] well written
you see
you can make a shitty movie
but it make it so enjoyable and so
[ __ ] funny that your eyes will be
glued to it the whole time
and you're just amazed you can't believe
you see it
yeah well yeah that's what i'm and
that's what i keep saying and i think
that's why frankenhooker
works so well and why it's still a
beloved cult classic nowadays
is because it took just a completely
absurd premise
and went all the [ __ ] way with it
yeah it knows it's absurd
and it just like when it went balls to
the wall we're gonna have exploding
hookers we're gonna have
super crack we're gonna have like all
kind of you know what i mean it's
all kind of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] just like
boobs everywhere
yeah and the dude playing lil swell he
has a lot of good scenes he does a lot
of funny [ __ ] and he
he's almost breaking character because
he knows this [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
ridiculous
but he gets through it like he's you
know
talking sweet to his girlfriend and
she's just ahead and trying to have
dinner with her and [ __ ] you know
pouring wine in her mouth and it's
coming out her nickel
and he's reading what are you eating
love poems or something to her oh my god
that poem yeah reading love poems
oh my god i love that poem he's on the
verge of busting up
but it doesn't matter i mean i imagine
it was probably pretty hard to keep it
straight yes
it's funny man that guy's name is uh
james lawrence
actually he got cast in this movie when
uh
frank henningwater saw him in street
trash yeah
which uh was the one about all the bums
melting yeah you remember that one yeah
that one wasn't that good i don't
remember i don't think that
yeah i couldn't really like i liked
parts of it but i couldn't really get
into it
it lost it lost the plot yeah going down
its own way the first
the first 15 minutes was good but then
it's like let's stick with the melting
bombs
kind of like kind of like
[Laughter]
transfers transfers was only good in the
first 15 minutes and the rest of it just
[ __ ] fell apart
how do you know because as a kid i
remember liking it and watching it again
i'm like this is a piece of [ __ ] man
there's no [ __ ] story here
well probably because they had a really
really good idea and they just didn't
like developing it yeah they didn't
develop yeah but see the thing that i
like about frankenhooker
is that i mean you already well you
already had a framework
obviously because you have frankenstein
yeah so you already have like a you know
framework to work within
and then he's like okay but what if this
guy wanted to make it out of hookers and
it's like
everything that stems from that
it's like yeah we're just gonna do all
of that yeah and then like i said with
the addition of the exploding
hookers like with the super crack and
everything which actually was a
was an aspect of it that i had forgotten
about um
so it's just and then her coming back to
life
and initially she doesn't remember
who she is all she remembers is that
she's a hooker
yeah so she just like goes around
repeating some of the stuff that the
other hookers said
like before they blew up yeah want a
party yeah
it's like some company and she keeps
making that face
that girl that played her uh patty
mullen she was the penthouse pet that
year
she was cute yeah yeah and it's funny
because at the very beginning like
before she gets killed by the um
by the lawn mower there the big joke is
that she's fat
even though she's not well she was
wearing a fat suit but it's just mostly
her butt looked kind of big
and like they put her in really
unflattering clothes and she kept eating
pretzels all the time
um which you know i i feel like donuts
or cupcakes would have been better but
okay pretzels
and uh so so i guess like the
implication being that she kind of had a
big butt
and so if her head got severed and then
her boyfriend was like hey i'm gonna
break it but i'm only gonna have like
the best pieces
yeah see i think what happened was when
he was going
because he didn't initially he was
trying to think about how to get body
parts and he had only two days to do it
because to get the amount of power he
needed he needed like this big storm was
coming
right so he had like a limited amount of
time and initially i don't think he
thought about
hookers but then he thought oh yeah like
they'll just come with me willingly
and i think he initially came up with
the crack idea
because he didn't want to kill them
outright but he remember he saw that
news segment about oh
all the prostitutes looks like they're
addicted to crack and that'll kill so
well the crack will eventually kill him
anyway so it's not even like i'm killing
him
yeah you just didn't see the movie
that's fine he um
he it's a crazy idea it worked though
it worked but now he was going to
replace her with like the ultimate body
because this was pre-j low so the white
boys weren't into
they didn't understand thick the way she
was before she blew up they probably
would like that better than a lot of the
skinny [ __ ] but yeah they had but
anyway
because really it's funny because it was
kind of like it was an epic homage to
natural breasts this one because they
didn't have any implants in this one did
you notice that i think maybe one girl
had implants oh yeah
they were all naturals looking i was
going yeah this is very much kind of
like uh
late 80s you know late 80s was the era
of the natural
porn star breast and i believe those
girls were mostly porn stars i'm pretty
sure
most of them well a lot of them uh were
strippers yeah dancers
some of the ones in the long shots you
know the parts where he was driving
around looking for the best street with
all the best looking hookers
a lot of those were actually real sex
workers yeah because they didn't really
like i said i don't know
i don't think i ever saw that they
mentioned that they didn't have any
permits
yeah um but they did film some of those
women like without asking them but i
guess it was like from a distance
jennifer lopez mainstream to the [ __ ]
thick look the big booty look
all right and then you had pam anderson
who mainstreamed the [ __ ] huge
implant look
yeah and that had not yet happened yet
in men's culture
at night by 1990. that took a while
baywatch was around but
it wasn't until like the advent of
howard stern
and [ __ ] tommy lee and pamela and
anderson tate came
out and everything and before they
really got big they [ __ ] just started
seeing girls [ __ ]
getting barbed wire [ __ ] tattooed
around their arms and [ __ ] those huge
[ __ ] implants
yeah because most of the women in this
were pretty thin kind of thin and normal
they were still kind of in the
in what we call the cocor phase not that
thin
yeah but close also i will say too well
we forgot to mention too
uh how many movies can you mention that
have
essentially a plate of titties yeah yeah
and the city's coming up there's
there's so much [ __ ] happening i can't
[ __ ] spoil it i mean
and then like all the hooker parts kind
of like merging
yeah yeah well now you're on no it's not
it's like until like i said it's an old
one there's a whole
[ __ ] attack of the hooker parts
it's just it builds up into into a grand
finale that is
that is worthy of um from beyond and
reanimator
it's like that yeah like i said it's a
it's like a sleazy or yeah
it's easier and the budget isn't quite
as high but
the practical effects were effective
enough to where it got it did get it
done
and the tone is comedic so it doesn't
have to
be that look that real to be scary
you're just supposed to go what the [ __ ]
they're not going to do that oh they're
doing that
they're doing this well and the the very
awesome it is it's an awesome movie
i love frank and hooker so much
genuinely i really do love frank
and frank the frankenhooker herself
in 1990 she would have been pretty far
out looking but really go to the goth
club and you see that all the time the
same boots and everything
yeah i used to have a pair of shoes
almost exactly like that
and with the blue hair and actually what
she was wearing would have been
considered kind of conservative
for a goth club of today you're like you
wear that conservative ass tight dress
where's the midriff you know why is your
ass hanging on the back of that
funny [ __ ] like that you know but it's
still a great movie you know
i liked it and the frankie hooker she is
cute well yeah it's a penthouse pad
yeah yeah yeah she was she did a good
job she did a good job playing the role
she was she looked like she was having a
good time
i liked all the goofy [ __ ] she did with
her face i liked i just really liked her
physicality
like the way she was walking yeah there
was one scene that like made me laugh
out loud where she takes her purse so
like until like puts her arm that like
drops it and it's like that just made me
laugh like the way she moved her arm
i thought was funny is that when she
came to life she was not only just
dressed already with her
that she already had her purse yeah and
was carrying the purse walking out
walking out of the operating room with
the purse going with the big platforms
yeah that's the platform with this
ready to go to work that's what i mean
and i think what makes this
work and this is maybe something we've
talked about why
certain movies even certain movies that
are trying to be
comedies uh horror comedies don't work
as well
because i think what works in this one
is one that the guy that plays
jeffrey is not zany he plays it like
pretty pretty straight straight yeah and
i think that works really well
and a lot of the stuff they kind of play
straight i particularly like at the
beginning
that he very clearly has a tank with a
brain with a big eyeball in it that he's
like bringing to life
and nobody like finds this alarming at
all everyone's just like oh there's
jeffrey doing his thing it's like nobody
and that's like way funnier to me his
mom sees it and everything
yeah that's like way funnier to me than
like people overreacting to [ __ ] or like
trying
like to go overboard with zayn yeah if
he was hungry we're making something to
eat
i know well that was another funny scene
that was another funny scene too and
that's along the lines of what i'm
talking about where he goes into this
long diatribe about
how depressed he is and it's like i feel
like you know after his girlfriend dies
and i feel him going to this big black
void and it's this big long thing
and then his mom like looks at him he's
like you want a sandwich
you know what i mean it's like it's just
like little things like that it's just
like really funny because i think that
your mom would do that
yeah that's true they're not really
listening to you no there's like
whatever ken
yeah you know i gave birth to you what
more do you want but it's yeah it was
that kind of thing which i mean sure
the mom was nice but that's that's kind
of the thing about that i feel like if
you have a concept
that insane that it's much funnier
for everyone to kind of play it straight
to an extent or not like overplay it
because the the concept is nutty enough
on its own and i think it's much funnier
if everyone just kind of downplays it a
little bit i don't know that's funnier
to me maybe that's not like funnier to
other people
but i think that's kind of what works a
lot in this one so a lot of the [ __ ]
that i found
really funny other than the scene with
like the exploding hookers which is
[ __ ] hilarious
um you will just like laugh your ass off
and they're obviously mannequins but
one i see okay so i don't know the story
went
that they used mannequins because they
said well
we didn't want to show realistic looking
special effects blowing up because we
would have gotten
an nc17 rating because nc 17 that rating
had just started that year
um so i that's the story that they went
with
but i don't know if that's true
or if they're just like well we couldn't
uh you know be bothered
to like make anything that was more
realistic or we couldn't afford it
either way
the tone of the movie uh dictates that
real
realism is not a factor in this movie
that this movie
is about entertainment i mean it's a
whole
that are exploding you're supposed to be
laughing so it
and then the muscles and then a muscle
dude wearing zubaz
gets knocked out by one of the hookers
flying heads yeah i mean come on
how could you not love this movie yeah
it is just so
super charming um and super fun and
all kinds of funny [ __ ] happens between
zorro and his buddy at the bar too
yes like you losing all your hill
hookers they all blow up because i
didn't lose them they blew up
none of the other pimps believed him
well that's what you wouldn't i mean you
know what i mean that's what that's what
was so funny to me that like i said that
everything is just kind of played
straight
yeah and it's just like just so so funny
and like i said um
you know i love basket case i love brain
damage but honestly of those three
movies frankenhooker is easily my
favorite i just think this is
it's just so so fun and so entertaining
and just everybody in it is good and
it's just like
you know like i said it's kind of a
classic of trash cinema it's a cult
classic for a reason
if you haven't seen it you really get
some [ __ ] uh
liquor yeah and sit down and [ __ ]
invite some friends over
watch the exploding hookers watch the
super crack
it's just so [ __ ] funny and just a
delightful delightful movie
uh it's on shutter at the moment might
also be on
to be i'm not entirely sure about that
although i would recommend watching it
on shutter because there's no
commercials
uh but yeah definitely check it out if
you haven't seen it it's [ __ ]
hilarious
and you will laugh your ass off just
like we did
we will see you guys on the next one bye